everything is special in the 1930s farm
goods are special and we have to
quote/unquote stabilize the market and
then we have labor relationships release
is special then of course you can't
allow people in New York City to figure
out how to rent an apartment because
real estate is special anytime you call
something special it's the Mark of Zorro
it's the Mark of Cain on your forehead
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we are sitting down with Richard
Epstein he is the Lawrence a Tisch
professor at New York University law he
also has an appointment at the
University of Chicago and at the Hoover
Institution Richard thanks for talking
to us oh it's always a pleasure let's
get to it you were among the people who
predicted the that Obamacare would fail
not simply because it was bad a bad idea
but the implementation would be
virtually impossible to do in the
Obamacare exchanges now we are seeing so
you know basically it some sort of death
spiral or some kind of predictable
outcome talk a little bit about that and
you know what is happening and why
didn't more people see it coming well I
I think we start with the second
question for us why do more people
didn't see it coming and I think the
explanation really is that these were
all the kind of Ivy League super jocks
and what they always believed is that
they could defeat the law of gravity by
the ingenious schemes that they would
put into place in order to keep things
under control so when this thing was
actively debated in 2008 and 2009 there
were two approaches to the problem
people like myself said look you know
health care insurance is not set not
really special but you have to
understand about all insurance scheme is
that the greatest chance of Canali be is
typically with the insured and not with
the insurer and I said the way in which
we kind of know this is you go back to
the history of marine insurance and you
start to see that the insurance
companies were always given the options
to pull out because they understood that
the concealment of information by the
insurance would have very adverse
effects on what they did and it was also
clear that the people who would come for
insurance were those who had private
information we'd made it made it more
likely than average that they would be
the ones who would need the stuff but
don't we solve this this is oh well we
know I'll stop you right there Richard
you know you're at NYU and Chicago
an Ivy League school we fix that because
you have to buy insurance well we didn't
fix it because of that first of all what
we do is we say you have to buy it but
the mandates are extremely unpopular and
the idea that you're going to run a
social program with great popular
acceptance which says you have to pay if
you don't want to take something that
you don't want to buy a really sticks in
the craw of
just about everybody because this is
sort of the kind of libertarian moment
that is respected by all people because
it's not dealing with what large
business an industry does it's stealing
with what you have to do in your
particular life so what you have to do
is to tell people we want you to go into
these plans and you're gonna be damned
if you do and you're damned if you don't
well you're damned if you do because it
turns out many of the people are going
to be forced in are those who will be
forced to pay premiums higher than the
actual value of the policy because the
implicit assumption and all systems of
social insurance is that you have cross
subsidies against different groups so
that one guys are going to be running
for the exit and then there's another
group which is going to be diving to get
into the program because they'll be
paying average rates of insurance for
superior levels of coverage so that's I
mean basically this is you know if
you're under 30 you're paying a lot more
than you would in the in the free market
or what passes for the free market
insurance and to get less stuff but then
if you're over 50 or over 45 you're
actually getting a real break and so it
means some more people the more people
older people go in they tend to be
sicker they tend yeah well use even
worse than that I mean the basic ratio
is you know typical person in their 20s
is gonna pay about 20 percent of the
improvements of the sick person in the
60 but remember there's going to be a
dispersion amongst the people inside the
20 and there'll be some of these people
unfortunately who will be quite sick
they will know that they're quite sick
and so they will join into the system at
the same level they're people in their
60s who are very healthy and they will
decide to stay out of the system so even
though you're talking about the basic
situation what you're doing is you're
under estimating the level of the skew
because private information will mean
that both groups will be self selecting
in a very powerful right and and the
whiz kids who put this together they
they did not even consider that or they
missed the math they didn't understand
the multiples of the
of the kind of sign I think what they
did is they understood the math but I
think they thought that they would be
able to persuade people morally or
otherwise to do this they also missed
another feature which has been explained
to me in which I had missed for a long
period of time we treat this as though
it's a matter of individual people
enrolling in these particular plans but
people who are sick are always met
remember of various kinds of health
groups so if you have a kid with due of
juvenile diabetes you join all the
associations online to learn about these
associations then direct you to the way
in which you can enroll so that instead
of it being a relatively slow resorting
of the marketplace these interest groups
tend to drive things much more rapidly
on the other side when you start to deal
with people who want to get out of the
plan they now realize that oddly enough
there is a market alternative which was
not that commonly available under
Obamacare and that's the walk in medical
care City MD and so forth so if you turn
out not to be a part of these programs
you can get pretty good primary care
without having to endure the ordeal of
an emergency room by getting yourself
involved with one of these things so it
turns out that there is rapid entry on
one side which was underestimated and
rapid exit on the other side that was
underestimated and what strangely
happened is given that the rules of the
game were established by Obama can then
market forces come in and they
accelerate the movement in both
directions and so by the time this thing
turns out to be done what happens is all
the individual plans which are not
buffered essentially are going to go
belly-up and you know I said this I
can't tell you how many times in 2008
and 2009 and when you were always met
with was this sort of you know superior
IV Links nearby individuals who knew so
much better than you as to how to run
this route Goldblatt compaction that
they thought they could defeat the law
of gravity let's just put it out that
you do have an Ivy League degree or in
your background okay so you okay so this
is like this is the equivalent of you
making fun of your own mother you can do
it oh well I will happily do that I mean
look I was always in the Ivy League in
terms of my education but I was always
out of the Ivy League in terms of my
general intellectual dispositions and
the reason I feel so strongly about this
issue in so many case
is I was always at places with people
clever than myself putting up schemes
that were dumber than anything that you
could ever imagine that was the kind of
intellectual environment you went to a
little bit of Columbia College and even
more at the air law school at Oxford
which is another very elite institution
what was striking about the English
experience is that the pro-labor
sentiment on the part of just about
everybody in town was just inordinate
and I get there in 1964 stay till 1966
and I watched the slow-motion decline of
the English system which essentially
imploded when Martha's Margaret Thatcher
took over in 1980 so I've been around
failure for a long time and what happens
is people just don't seem to change
their mind in response to adverse
information well just to kind of stick
on that point for a second do you think
in today's world you know clearly
something like Obamacare centralizes
power in many ways in the healthcare
industry you point to a couple ways in
which it's actually also created markets
that didn't exist before
but is this a bigger or worse problem
than it's ever been of a kind of elite
dictating more and more parts of our
lives not because they're not trying to
but do we have more you know is power
centralizing or decentralizing in any
kind of understandable way in American
society well I think it's clearly
centralizing in parties in the Congress
but more conspicuously in the last eight
years it's tends to centralize in the
president because what happens is George
Bush sort of made announcements of
murmurs that he would engage in
executive vetoes of one kind or another
or initiatives but he was never prepared
to fight the nuclear option Obama comes
into the office and while he'd been a
critical presidential power was in the
Senate when he faces a Congress which is
essentially trying to frustrate most of
what he does he doesn't take any
objection by Republicans as being
legitimate he simply says that they're
obstructionist so I'm gonna do it to the
extent that I can't by myself so
unilateralism becomes a dominant mode
and now when you have you know what is
the president more effective you know
our single you know the president
President Obama has been trying to do
all sorts of things that he can't get
done or that people are just like forget
about it is he controlling immigration
policy is he might try to control
immigration policy he gets rebuffed by
the courts but more to the point
he's rebuff by immigrants because
they're not coming because the economy
sucks so I mean that's what I'm getting
at in a large sense is our fully only
going in a centralized way or is you
know are there all of these kind of
loopholes well what happens when you
centralize power in a president it's
what they said about the little girl
when she was good she was very very good
and when she was bad she was hard what
happens is you don't have the buffer of
multiple institutions so you could tend
to lurch one way or another if you have
strong movements of government power
what you will do is have decentralized
responses to it by people we're trying
to minimize the result so what you do is
you get politics at both levels you get
people being very politically directive
at the center and then people being
politically responsive on the outside in
an effort to sort of minimize the flow
so for example on Obamacare what happens
is we are now entering into a compliance
culture in which if you do something
wrong the sanctions are always red cone
Ian so you a have to have somebody to
fix it so you don't get punished and B
you have to make sure that all your
ducks in order so that if something goes
wrong you can have all sorts of defenses
against these kinds of things well the
compliance culture essentially requires
industry concentration to be acceptable
if you double the size of a firm you
don't double the size of your compliance
cost so one of the things that Obamacare
has done is it it's led to a wave of
hospital and industry mergers in an
effort to minimize compliance costs
thereby creating higher levels of market
concentration which leads to monopoly
power and the reason why that's bad is
because then they can be or tend to they
become overly bureaucratic so they they
don't have to respond to customer
demands
yeah this was one of the one of the
central choice that you face in a
political situation when you see an
imperfection is this follows either you
try to try to remove it or you try to
create a compensating imperfection and
my view is you always do the form you
never do the ladder so if they're
restraints on entry which make the
markets relatively monopolistic at the
state level what you do is you allow
insurance companies that operate outside
the state to sell business inside the
state in order to create essentially
more levels of
what Obama did was essentially cut a
deal with the insurance companies he
said you join in my monopolistic program
I'm gonna make sure that the barriers
against entry are in place so what you
do is you get a dumb monopoly instead of
a reasonably intelligent competitive
system this gets done over and over
again there's always the tendency to say
ah this doesn't work so now we have to
put that in place well it turns out that
the cure that you have the disease is
not specific to the disease and what you
do is you now create distortions and
third Marcuse's then you play the game
over and over again so there's always
this constant ready supply of
justification for mettlesome
interventions and it's gonna ruin all
markets whatever they run I've heard
some people who are you know kind of
trying to find a pony under the the pile
of Obamacare say you know one possible
good thing is that by pushing more and
more providers or more and more
companies and you know employers to
having high deductible you know low
premium high deductible plans that for
that first 3,000 or first $5,000 that
you're paying out-of-pocket for various
things that that will actually create
market incentives and I know this going
back because I've been on a high
deductible plan for years before
Obamacare at various points I would go
into my the doctor and for the first
time I would he would say oh here's a
drug for something and I would ask him
how much that cost and he would actually
ask you know somebody in the office to
find out what it was and then say yeah
you know what that's kind of expensive
here's a cheaper alternative market
forces at work do you think Obamacare is
pushed towards that kind of lower high
deductible thing will that help create a
market and will that help medical care
or will it just kind of be closed in in
in another one salsa city and D
phenomena it turns out that if the plans
are so clunky and so expensive and if
you can't actually give things people
the things that they want you have to
give them things that they don't want
you're gonna basically do this by having
a deductible now they're spending their
own money for a large portion of the
situation and they will tend to it you
know there have been many studies for
example looking at the cost of cosmetic
surgery as opposed to the cost of
covered surgery and cosmetic is elective
but people care a great deal about it
but they shop for this because they know
it's paying from
out of their own pockets and you know
this very simple view that people
actually take into account costs and
benefits when they bear both will tend
to ignore course when they're born by
somebody else it's thought to be one of
these shibboleths that only a
chicago-based market economist can
believe but in fact medical care health
care like a couple of other things yeah
it's totally different everything is
special I mean years ago I wrote a
series of papers on my health care is
special claiming that it isn't special
and the moment you start to make it
special
it just turns out to overheat in
particular ways but the special metaphor
is used everywhere so to give you an
example in the 1930s we start
introducing the Agricultural Adjustment
Act which completely wrecked farm prices
why do we do it because farm goods are
special why they especially because
they're highly responsive to changes in
supply and demand which is a good thing
and we have to quote-unquote stabilize
the market it's a disaster and then we
have labor relationships well these are
special and why they special because
these employees have complete dominant
power even in competitive markets so
even in the face of rising wages when
productivity increases we unionize this
stuff and we create the imbalances
because labor markets turn out to be
special then of course rental is clearly
special you can't allow people in New
York City to figure out how to rent an
apartment you have to put a rent
stabilization program in there because
real estate is special anytime you call
something special it's the Mark of Zorro
it's the Mark of Cain on your forehead
you are about to kill a particular
market in the name of trying to make it
accessible and affordable to everybody
you know we're trying to reach a wider
and wider audience with reason TV so
let's have you had work done let's go
back to cosmetic surgery
you look fabulous have you had work done
absolutely not but if you did you would
shop for the best price I would have my
wife shop for the best guys I mean I I
understand where these portions of
agency work their best and they don't
work with me I'm a terrible consumer as
it turns out so I delegate the
responsibility to somebody who is a
terrific consumer so well let's talk
about another special case of kind of
law enforcement or government
investigation and this has to do with
state's attorneys generals going after
Exxon Mobil and we assume many many
other companies and many many other
fields but claim
essentially analogizing between tobacco
companies and the research that they
generated knowing about the carcinogenic
effects of their products to ExxonMobil
knowing about global warming
tell us walk us through what is the case
that the attorneys general are trying to
make and what do you say well first of
all I think you actually have to
understand the tobacco cases better than
it's commonly known and I say this is
somebody who actually as a rabid aunty
smoker organized much of the defense's
you're to the left of Hitler on the
antique smoker oh I mean I just hate
smoke okay but I actually represented
Philip Morris for many years and I try
to figure out how it is you put together
the defenses in the tobacco cases
because if you believe in a notion of
individual responsibility and you start
to think that the risk of tobacco a
covert and latent you're living in a
myth man I could recall in 1952 is my
radiology father we were all the kids
riding him about being a smoker saying
dad why do you want to kill yourself
when you know that this stuff is very
very dangerous and we actually got him
to quit and so you know minded that big
what because nobody knew until the
Surgeon General put no that's completely
not obvious I mean you just look the
cigarettes were called coffin nails in
the 1930s Reader's Digest put this huge
expose out in 1952 it but it is true
also that the tobacco companies kept a
constant line of information going out
about yeah mitigating or military or
just saying no it's not at all yeah I
agree they should not have done that my
view about it is it was completely
ineffective in part because the
information that you got from
independent sources was much more bad
but let me give you another one of the
ironies about all of this they one of
the things is there was a program I
think it was by Chesterfield which says
medical doctors and I show you a guy
with a thing over his eyes tell you that
Chesterfields are easy on your t-zone
smoked Chesterfields right what do you
think the effect of that particular
commercial was well it had two effects
one is if you didn't smoke Chesterfields
if what these guys are telling you is
that chest of these other cigarettes are
really deadly so for the first time the
dangers of cigarettes were brought home
by the cigarette companies and then
people hooked the chest if you only said
why these guys different from anybody
else yeah so the effect of these ads to
give you medical
Shirin PSA's essentially reduced the
level of smoking more dramatically in
the 70s and the warnings of 1964 should
they paid out anything to smokers no I
mean we organized the defense's and they
never did pay out anything to smoke they
paid out many things to Medicaid and
it's a big difference what happened with
the cigarette cases is when we came up
there this we had a two-part defense and
the first part of the defense was to
explicate what it means to talk about
tobacco increasing the risk of various
serious health helps the stupid position
would be to deny this the correct
position is to say that when you're
talking about this it is not the same
kind of causation you get when you're
hit by a falling brick the probability
of getting cancer increases with smoking
but it's a curve and you have to figure
out what it is it turns out that the
really- Act adverse effects tend to be
delayed in telling them and the
frequency is not quite as high as many
people go so you're certainly talking
about a risk which to me was large
enough that I never wanted to get near
this stuff but if people really find
that cigarettes give them some other
collateral advantage you can explain an
equilibrium wide is that they're gonna
smoke as the information gets better
that cigarettes are more dangerous what
happens is you start to see a systematic
decline in the rate of smoking and in
the toxicity of the cigarettes that are
being smoked on one of the real negative
Scitex laws it starts in the late night
the mid to late 1950s by this particular
time you start seeing the rise of the
filter tips cigarettes and so forth you
start seeing low-tar low-nicotine if you
look at the brand switches the pall
malls and the old goals which were the
really deadly ones I start to go out so
it turns out that the rate of smoking
goes down and the toxicity of the
particular cigarette starts to go down
which is perfectly consistent with a
rational market of information being
absorbed and you know the cigarette
companies may have done some terrible
things at the time and I've seen some of
this stuff and I really don't want to
defend any of that but when it came to
the smoking stuff we gave this account
of causation and then we went on the
assumption of risk side the most famous
case was ROS chip alone and by god
everybody in her family from the
beginning of time to the end said rose
this stuff is gonna kill you it's gonna
hurt your baby why do you smoke it was
her doctor who's her minister who's a
family it was a friends
she knew all of this stuff and you could
never win these cases before a jury
precisely because the enormity of the
knowledge was an everyday affair to
these people and the fact that
somebody's putting out a commercial here
there or the other thing really isn't
dominating the information flow and this
was I think correct or the way the
cigarette companies got beaten is the
Medicaid arguments made by the provider
saying we actually had to pay these
particular people to take care of you
and we have an independent cause of
action this is bogus as a matter of
general law but the moment you allow for
the independent cause of action it turns
out all the assumption of risks defenses
disappear and so it now becomes a
collection case and you can make a
fortune
which they promptly do and then they
securitize this stuff and the great
irony is once the tobacco companies make
the settlement with these states on this
various issues what they do is they now
have a protector because the states
don't want that cash flow to disappear
they make it impossible for new
cigarette companies with chief tar a low
tar and nicotine to enter into the
market because you now have a
government-sponsored cartel the state
owns a fraction of the tobacco comes in
every year or every couple of years you
hear states starting to complain about
how they're getting bringing in less and
less money from tobacco settlements so
what are they gonna do next
well I they're not gonna get a few mixed
on mobile if that's what the question is
I think it's just a dying stream of
revenue so well talked about okay and so
I mean just so we're clear you don't
think tobacco companies should shouldn't
have paid anything to anybody beyond you
know the taxes that they paid well yes I
mean look I was and this was the
position in the Restatement second of
torts in 1965 this was the common
position the way in which it was stated
is good tobacco that was the words in
the Restatement and basically is
something that we expect because there's
no deviation between what you get and
what you want but if it's contaminated
with something like marijuana that's
what was there by mr. Prosser and when I
worked for Philip Morris I mean one of
the questions I asked him is what would
you do if you found out that you had a
defective bunch of tobacco was
contaminants that could hurt and this is
what they said if we thought there were
a thousand cigarettes like this we would
move a million from the market
because we knew that if a single product
deviated from the expectations that we
had we worked we are slaves to our
reputation and we move aggressively this
is true of every consumer product and
the idea that they fed a stream of
disinformation or misinformation to
consumers or to regulators or anything
that that's really not appropriate or
relevant here well I think nobody
believed it'd be again I have you'd have
to go back and read these things because
what happens is they did say things that
you would disagree with but whether it
was open and shut in the way in which it
was put remember all the guys were
putting the spin and interpretation of
this on the plaintiffs lawyers and you
know my view is if I went back and I
read these evidences one after another I
would find some of them less credible
some of them more credible there's
always some degree of doubt I mean one
of the things that I think is widely
misunderstood is the rate at which the
increased risk takes place the best work
in this stuff was actually done by a guy
hired by the pack of copies a guy named
kif excused yeah and in his rates of
information on this we're much lower
than those which we'll put on the other
side and merely just have you know
Ronald Reagan famously or Jackie
Robinson or opera singer saying you know
this it cools my throat or it gives me
an app that's not fraud and you know
that's not actually what we call poor
that's what we call puff but those ads
were actually blocked by 1960 right
there used to be standard baseball
endorsement Stan Musial smokes X Y & Z
cigarette I mean I'm not look I don't
want to say that this is not crazy and
let's suppose we did find out that there
was some degree of systematic fraud by
the companies the correct response is a
font by the government which tries to
measure roughly speaking what the social
cost is but given the fact that there's
so many sources of information the
thought that this information is
decisive in any man any more than a tiny
fraction of the smoking cases strikes me
as being wildly overstated and it's
interesting because you know when people
like Vacco come out and say well I'm
against Exxon Mobil prosecution but I
did the cigarette sentiment you read
what he said about them and and it turns
out he doesn't quite get the case you
know the tobacco companies won the
following litigation every time a health
provider that was not Medicaid
came forward and said all costs have
been increased because your
representations to smokers have led them
to increase smoking and so therefore you
always the increased cost of care for
these people every single court that
faced those issues said no these
particular damages are much too remote
it was only the peculiar and special
status of Medicare which meant that the
public side could get money so you talk
about but Medicare Medicaid what is it
about those programs it's the only
Medicaid Medicaid rather
government-funded health the health
insurance why did that well I was not a
decisive day what they what happened is
they these people said we have a
government obligation in order to take
care of these people
and since you increase the particular
work that we have to do you have to pay
for the increased cost the traditional
rule about this had always been the
exact opposite suppose there was a
smoker who got Medicaid coverage Oh what
would happen is he would then be asked
to assign the health portion of his tort
claim against the tobacco companies to
the government to pursue the basic rule
on this assignment or the subrogation
claim is always that you take subjects
of the defense's that could be raised
against the smoker so if you treat this
as a derivative action from the smoker
all the assumption of risk stuff of
public and private comes in and we went
as a tobacco companies but if you treat
it as an independent cause of action
with a statutory base which the private
guys don't have and then it turns out
you lose and then what you do is you get
very favorable judgments on causation
because it's assumed that everything
that happened would have been different
if the information flow had been
different from the government but that
of course is overstated given the huge
amounts of private information that
people chose to disregard because they
wanted to smoke so I don't think that
these cases are easy I as I said I'm a
strong anti smoker but one of the
advantages as a matter of fact I think
you'd likened yourself to Hitler
lidocaine's antes well I think you were
worse than Hitler well well whatever it
is I've never had a cigarette in my life
and I take a lot of credit in persuading
many people who should have known better
to quit starting when I was a boy how
old are you now 73 okay you know do you
want to try we can we can run out and
get some say no I have no desire
whatsoever that would be
relating moment it would be essential I
would regard it as a mortal death threat
I just don't want to have a puff of that
stuff in me but you know I think most
people understood that they have
different trade-offs for me and look one
of the things about having a no
liability regime which is actually
important is that when people decide to
smoke they realize they're gonna have to
bear the consequences of this and so
it's a nice sort of gentle reminder to
you that costly activities the course is
going to be born on you if you give the
warranty then you externalise the course
as well so let's talk about this new
case which is kind of fascinating about
the idea that you know attorneys
generals who you know Lord love them
they're pretty inventive but now they
want to go after ExxonMobil for the
effects of global warming talk a little
bit about that well I mean first of all
I think they did want to do this there
was this great press conference in the
end of March of this year in which Eric
Schneiderman trotted out the hapless and
Al Gore and they sort of announced that
well the First Amendment doesn't protect
fraud and all these companies have been
gauged in systemic fraud on global
warming and we're gonna go after them
and he said I have the Martin Act to do
this I'm actually doing a fairly
detailed study on the Martin Act now for
the Manhattan Institute and it certainly
gives you a leg up in these particular
cases but no decisive to explain the
more the Martin Act well first of all to
explain what the Martin Act is you have
to understand what the basic common law
rules of fraud or and we commonly talk
about a kind of a Fivefinger fraud and
in order for it to be fraud there has to
be see enter that is knowledge that the
statement that you would make is false
or reckless disregard as to whether it's
true or false then it actually has to be
a statement of fact it can't be a
prediction it can't be an opinion then
it turns out that somebody has to rely
on it that's the causal connection he
has to rely on it to his detriment and
then it turns out that he has to have
injury and in addition to this generally
speaking it's required that the
statements on which people rely on
material that is sufficiently important
so that they would move the rational
investor and when you refer to the PUF
you know this is the best cigarette in
town materiality is the opposite of the
puffery and puff has never been regarded
as fraud so if you say this is the fine
restaurant on the southside of Chicago
and eighteen people are saying and you
can sue 17 of them for fraud so that's
the basic situation but the Martin Act
tended to do is to relax some of the
requirements it said you don't have to
prove sienta but in most of these cases
it was perfectly evident that it
happened then it would say that you
don't have to prove individual reliance
because you're making these
announcements to the world and we don't
want people buying worthless stock and
we're going to enjoin it before we
actually is reliance taking place and
then we said we don't have to prove
damages and if you're dealing with
injunctions that's also perfectly
sensible because why do you want to have
to have people get injured when you
could stop the injury beforehand and
when applied to sort of garden-variety
commercial frauds as was originally done
from starting in the 20s and so forth
the more neck was useful Eliot Spitzer
comes along and he decides to rev it up
going against public corporations and
it's a little bit more complicated Hank
Greenberg is the main target of this and
it's a very contentious sort of
litigation but now he's trying to do it
in the area of global warming and at you
see wait a second this is crazy first of
all let's just start with a single thing
what does mr. Eric Schneiderman know
about global warming I think the answer
is nothing whatsoever and so what I've
done is I've always been a skeptic on
the global warming side but it's
important to explain what skepticism
means there's a kind of a basic
fundamental formula round there widely
accepted by everyone on both sides that
what you do is you measure the change in
temperature as a function of the
increase say the doubling of carbon
dioxide and what it is the function is
logarithmic which means that if you
double something it turns out that the
actual change in temperature won't
double it will be less than that and the
question then is just how much there is
something called a sensitivity
coefficient and if that number is very
big then the effect is going to be very
large if that coefficient is small it's
going to be very small well the
proposition which says that everybody
understands that increases in carbon
dioxide results in increases in
temperature is true for anybody who
believes that this sensitivity
coefficient is greater than zero
everybody on every side of the debate
believes that the issue is not whether
or not there's an increase the issue is
how big is the coefficient which will
tell us how rapid the increase is going
to turn out to be on that question there
is an enormous amount of dispute the
IPCC the International Panel on Climate
control the UN type of operation tends
to put the coefficient that's three the
people who are more skeptical say it's
probably closer to one and much lower if
you then start they'll look at these
things the data is a better fit to the
lower coefficient more recently than it
is to the higher coefficient and even
this turns out to be somewhat mysterious
if you take the last 16 years the
increase in carbon dioxide
concentrations in the atmosphere it's
been about 13% the increase in
temperature over the same particular
period it's pretty close to zero the
other great measure that you're looking
at is the number of sort of storm like
events typhoons hurricanes and so forth
if you look at a graph there's a high
variability across years but there's no
question then if you took a single
trendline it's actually down rather than
up over the last 120 years so if you're
trying to put these two things together
what happens is it is sure that there's
some increase but it's much lower then
the question is just one more point is
and what's the consequence of the
increase well increases in carbon
dioxide without major increases in
temperature are wonderful because they
improve plant life so the issue is much
more complicated and if Exxon Mobil
changes its points of view maybe they
actually know something that mr.
Schneiderman doesn't so what are the
what are the AG's trying to do though
what I mean is this and is this just a
an assertion of will over an industry
that's very easy to vilify is I mean is
it that blank of abuse of power or is it
you know what are they hoping to get out
of this well actually it's very
interesting because this particular
campaign is in complete disarray
Snyderman thought he had put together an
alliance in March of this year but as he
started to go deeper and deeper into
this thing all the various other
attorney generals started to back off
there was this fellow called walk
in the Virgin Islands who wanted to put
some penis to the Competitive Enterprise
Institute and hey er to figure out
whether or not the people would receive
money from ExxonMobil had been crooks
and you know there was a huge blowback
on this because now it looks like it's
the Spanish Inquisition being run by
some ignoramus who doesn't have a large
stake in anything at all and so he's
backed off a little bit um it turns out
that Schneiderman has now backed off the
effort to try and figure out what they
did in the 70s 80s and 90s if you look
at the studies on which he relied these
sort of revelation by these various
climate groups the only reason why the
revelations look to be plaus was they
have complete certitude that they
understand what the impact is of the
climate change and if you look at other
people they don't so recently I spoke
with a group of physicists all retired
because I think they're worried about
political blowback and they've put
together something called the carbon
dioxide coalition so I've actually read
their literature and you know this is
the most boring literature imaginable
because it's a bunch of graphs and
tables and charts and so forth and you
come away from that stuff saying look
I'm not sure that they're right I mean
good scientific procedure says let them
be attacked by somebody on the other
side and then respond but the thought
that they can be ignored given their
data that they assembled in the
sophistication that they put it together
and would be something of a travesty
and so this entire climate debate has
been characterized by a shrillness and
dogmatism based on one sense that 97% of
the scientists in the world believe in
climate change well I would count myself
as one of that 97% if I were a scientist
but I'm not going to be somebody who's
gonna be you know sort of absolutely
alarmed about all of this stuff and
what's happened is when people start
using the word deniers they're trying to
bring back memories of the Holocaust and
they're saying look we will lose
millions of people to global warming and
it's just like what Hitler did on when
he slaughtered innocent people those
days well this is not that particular
situation future it's a prediction if
you're trying to figure out what the
remedies are one of the things that's so
disgraceful about the Obama
administration is they don't even know
how to put together an intelligent
program to deal with pollution and
there's so many things that they can do
which would limit this problem the
founders and others but they insist upon
using
antiquated environmental statutes
instead of retooling the entire project
from beginning let's let's talk about
Obama and his legacy he is still
president or at least that's what I read
in the newspapers and how would you sum
up his the effect that he has had you
know after two terms president taking
office during a difficult economic
moment and also you know passing what we
constantly are told a transformative
health care bill how do you sum up his
legacy what are the things that we
should be mindful of both of what he did
right and wrong and what we should be
looking to avoid or replicate in future
administer well I think the right list
is pretty short I can't think of any
major initiative that he made that I
agree with there's things on which he's
less bad there's things that he's kind
of neutral and then there's a largest
list of things that are terrible I mean
the first thing I think that one has to
say about it was he just absolutely
projects the wrong moral tone as
somebody who sits in high office he is
dogmatic beyond all possible belief and
yet his information base turns out to be
extraordinarily weak one of the things
that I always asked what I think about a
professor or a president is what was
their undergraduate education like and
it's quite clear he didn't have any at
that particular level so he works with a
very thin information base and he makes
these very striking the surgeon what's
an example of that well you start with
the global warming stuff you know the
guy looks out at a beautiful ocean and
he says I see just terrifying
consequences in the future but he has no
idea of whether this stuff is right or
wrong and if you actually ask him to sit
down and go into the science I'm not
even sure he knows what a logarithm is
which would be essential to figuring out
the way this thing works on the
healthcare stuff he's just dismissive of
every private organization so when they
had this disastrous rollout which
everybody knew was coming in 2012 this
man gets up and sort of announces to the
world well I'm getting rid of all these
crummy and private insurance plan and
I'm giving you a better plan he has no
idea of what the content of those
private plans was or what the public
plans are and it turns out the public
plans are just terrible because they
require you would buy the insurance on
things that you don't want whereas the
private plans tend to concentrate on the
things that
we'll start 2-1 so you throw six million
people off of there and at the same time
you one office in part because of this
insidious campaign against Mitt Romney
back in the summer of 2012 in which you
said when Bain Capital took over this
business one guy lost his health care
insurance and died of Kansas six years
later the individual instance was a
complete fabrication and the larger
implication that somebody else who works
in private business doesn't care about
individual people is crazy when eight or
nine million people lose their insurance
in the fall of 2012 business as usual
no just the transition when the system
starts to go bad they doctor the stuff
he writes this incredibly bad article in
the Journal of the American Medical
Association extolling a Obamacare I
don't know if you've read this thing and
it's a you know political piece he
didn't write a word of it as far as I
can tell he got some assistance writing
and he kind of uses to grandstand the
success of a program and never once and
that article talks about the adverse
collection collapse problem which is
taking place at the time that the thing
was written these are I'm just getting
started
yeah yeah no no I want to I want to give
you a second to really you know find the
eighth gear on the way up but you know
those are kind of personal observations
or their psychological observations
about that Obama where you know how does
he get so far if he has a thin knowledge
base if he his programs are bad and are
constantly family I mean if you've ever
met the guy remember he worked at the
University of Chicago I was as interim
dean for part of the time his first
impression is tremendously positive he
really knows how to carry himself
everything from his accent his voice and
smile and so forth it's the kind of
thing that brings people in and in
politics if you can make a very good
first impression you're going to do
pretty well he's also pretty a student
in managing to avoid getting involved in
things so if you wanted to take for
example the bungled situation with
respect to the potential indictment of
Hillary Clinton for various frauds of
one kind or another the most striking
thing about the president is he's
nowhere to be seen in this particular
discussion all it could do is to bring
him down so if you're looking for four
guys it's Jim Comey at the FBI and it's
Loretta Lynch sitting in the depart
- justice and God knows who else my
white side whoever I don't even know who
it is doing all of these things and he
tends to be able to stay out of the
particular frame kind of interesting
that you know we didn't nobody is asking
well where was he if she must have known
she was running a personal server yeah
yeah I mean all of this stuff I mean he
he just manages to keep out of this he
has a a press which is probably 80%
liberal I mean to put aside Fox News in
the Wall Street Journal they don't ask
him particularly hard question um and
what he does is he always manages to go
public with a speech about empathy
explaining how he's gonna start to help
me he also essentially he starts moving
in other areas now with populist fervor
um he's terrifically good at taking
after the banks I mean the prosecution
and the settlement with respect to the
JPMorgan Chase on the so-called Madoff
scandal was a true outrage I mean Eric
Holder and my judgment is one of the
worst attorney generals who ever served
in that aw why is that because he was
abusive with respect to the people whom
he hated and was unduly charitable to
the people whom he explained how that
played out it with you welcomed working
well with the what happened is Madoff
essentially use JPMorgan to distribute
payments to various people and there's
been an elaborate report by the
Securities and Exchange Commission
trying to figure out why it is that this
fraud to say protection of everybody
inside the business and all people on
the outside knew that the management of
the SEC and Santee fraud campaign was
terrible because matter of us turning
out a relatively stable rate of returns
and a high of all of the market this
Justin happened in the universe and
countless numbers of people many of whom
actually spoke to me about this said to
the SEC this does not look right to us
and they missed it all right so now they
have this guy he was not mentioned once
that is JPMorgan Chase in the entire
report they're giving our payments to
annual people and all of a sudden they
are the real culprits because if they
had warned us we would have done it so
let's find them ten twelve fourteen
billion dollars or whatever it is for
these things this is just outrageous
then the abuse of the Justice Department
with respect to various kinds of private
enterprises universities with the big
club either you
your civil rights protections in the
form that we wanted well we're gonna
pull all the money from your medical
research kinds of programs everybody
starts to capitulate under these kinds
of threats and so there is in this
administration the use of what they call
the guidance and what the guidance says
is this is not really enforceable but
don't you cross this anyhow even though
it's not enforceable and so we will then
throw the book at you so people
capitulate they don't have to give
notice and comment hearing they don't
have to do enforcement procedures and so
for example on the question of what kind
of hearing do start to give to people
charged with sexual harassment cases or
racial discrimination cases they say
that standard for a very serious charge
is simply a preponderance of the
evidence
no private university independently
would want to use that lowest standard
but sure enough once you get the Obama
threat everybody starts to capitulate
where is where is Congress during all of
this because you know and other forces
that should be pushing back Bhama has
faced I mean he helped create a
Republican Congress that he had to deal
with through his first two years in
office are they to blame or how does
their lack of action or potency factor
into an assessment of the Obama well but
you have to do is you understand that
Congress can do by way of investigation
and they do investigate but it's easy to
Stonewall investigations and all the
rest of that but if they try to pass
legislation it's subject to a
presidential veto and then once the
presidential veto comes into place the
sphere of executive action becomes very
much larger the only time that it really
matters that you get Congress is on some
of these big budget issues like the
showdown over the deficit and so forth
but otherwise his which the Republican
the Republicans were trying to break the
sequester yeah yes so they could spend
more money yes I'm not yeah no I know
you're not defending it I'm just saying
so yeah but on the military side it's
pretty unilateral with respect to the
president many libertarians are much
more dovish than I am but I think
virtually everybody agrees that he's
incompetent as a commander-in-chief and
you you think so because he hasn't been
interventionist enough but I don't see
has a coherent policy I think is the
first thing and he doesn't know how to
reassure his allies suppose you want to
be non interventionist you don't become
non
interventionists by essentially
announcing red lines in Syria and then
withdrawing you don't start making deals
with the Russian which gives them sway
you don't start to announce publicly
while they're gonna get themselves into
this quagmire which they will never
emerge and then it basically Putin
treats this kid as though he's a child I
mean when you don't bomb Libya
prevention who is the last president for
you you know I think you're right that
Obama does not have they Igor did not
articulate a clear coherent foreign
policy that could even be debated George
Bush kind of had one which was equally
disastrous I thought well let me give
you my book view there were three or
four foreign policies by Bush and I have
different attitudes towards all of them
on the question of whether or not to go
in or not the knowledge at the time I
was at Afghanistan and everybody wanted
to go well but then there went how large
you want yes they ran around but in Iraq
it was very tense I could recall at the
Hoover Institution attending briefings
by people were generally frightened out
of their wit's by the weapons of mass
destruction my own guess in retrospect
is this follows the reports that we
intercepted we read correctly but they
were all lies designed to would deceive
Saddam Hussein would otherwise kill them
if this program had not been advanced
and so we thought they were more
advanced than they were the war the
Liberals basically thought the thing
would be a disaster it was a pretty
effective war the occupation immediately
after that was a complete and total
disaster Bush had no idea of what to do
he put people in office who had no idea
to do they didn't know how to basically
deregulate the economy they basically
diem the Bathurst and they created all
sorts of enemies of one kind or another
and the place was a complete disaster
and then he got himself together and if
you saw what Petraeus did the guy was a
miracle man he managed he knew how to
run it and he was not just a military
guy he understood that whenever you want
to do these things it's a hearts and
minds operation it's a a cooperation
opposition you got to pay bribes to the
devil in order to keep them going he
wrote about this in foreign affairs in
20 and 13 and his crew he was remarkable
so 2009 comes you have an uneasy
stability and then Obama makes it very
clear he's a short term this is a
terrible mistake
whatever your views were about the first
three stages getting in fighting the war
the first failure then their surge you
have to play the hand that you were
dealt and the moment we made it clear
that we were gonna get out it was very
clear that chaos would break out there
it became very clear to everybody else
that the United States would not
intervene anyway and so it's a
free-for-all so we're so there where
were in Libya before I mean this is I am
with I get it always in places where
we're in trouble because essentially
into what Powell said Colin Powell said
was correct either you stay or you get
in right yeah I do great and I think the
weight of evidence is now on the yeah
let's stay out because we're not very
good at staying in well I let me put it
this way Obama's commander-in-chief the
correct rules stay out yeah because he's
incompetent to trying to run one of
these things because he doesn't believe
in it if you had somebody why do you say
that I mean as opposed to he's
incompetent and he doesn't like what is
the evidence that he doesn't believe in
it what he doesn't believe that the
United States can forcibly reform
various countries and they probably he's
probably right about no I don't think
that's what I mean I mean I mean this is
obviously a point of contention between
us I think what happens is he does not
believe that the United States is better
than any other nation in anything that
it ever does he's very much an opponent
of American exceptionalism and he
constantly kind of thinks of us as a
colonialist power of one sort or another
so look there are many disastrous
interventions by the United States and
many pretty good ones but I think in his
particular case the presumption is that
were always worse than we are and what
happens is this gets communicated to the
rest of the world that the president
doesn't believe in his own country he's
always trying to figure out why we're
wrong so you know idle musings from a
president can be absolutely deadly so
this guy gets in and you see some of
these atrocities against the yzi knees
and so forth thousands of people giving
no concern what does the president do
says well remember the Crusades what
does he know about the Crusades I dare
say absolutely nothing one way or
another why they're relevant he never
sized
yeah I mean I don't disagree with kind
of your a lot of your thinking the
conclusions I guess you know for me I
don't understand how Obama thinks the
way that you say he does and but then
he's willing to bomb Libya he's willing
to use drone strikes all over the place
and he very clearly believes in his
exceptionalism and it's a new people
around him are able to plan and
distribute knowledge and peace so and
that was the first point about the
domestic economy I mean he certainly
does believe that I mean I wish he was
as non-interventionist as many of his
critics well are you in many cases I
would you have to do is you have to pick
your spot yeah
that's the first thing the second thing
is the question is how credible are your
threats that is when people start
looking at the United States seeing the
reduction in military power the
unwillingness to use it while the cat's
away the mice will play and so you now
start seeing other kinds of alliances
form in which the instabilities are
really great you see the situation in
Yemen and another proxy war taking place
you see the takeover in Crimea you see
the Chinese building islands in the
middle of the South China Sea and
starting to move there you see this is
where back at the Republican convention
well I well let me put it this way this
is a serious issue I mean if they can
call it a claim you know put up an
island which is a pinprick in the ocean
I have a 200 mile zone everywhere around
it in which they have exclusive control
by the same token the idea that I mean
this in many ways you're channeling I
think a kind of American Cold War policy
circa 1960 where it's wherever anybody
else says we need to be there and you
know some of these are regional issues
that really the rest of the American
government can't do much about and
shouldn't do well I look if you remember
1960 the great talking point for our
good friend John Kennedy was cream oil
and Matsu right two little islands was
just so under control of the
Nationalists but the idea that you go to
war over Queen moyen Matsu was crazy
Vietnam much more complicated kind
didn't work out so I didn't work out
well and of course there was there are
reasons again
I mean it's strange it's the same
problem Johnson goes in he's willing to
put in five hundred and thirty five
thousand troops at the top but he's not
willing to bomb in the north and he's
not willing to bomb churches so what
happens they use all the churches to
store all their material then you have
Kennedy's the Ivy League guy what does
he do he takes the M and throws him out
of office in November of 1963 before
he's assassinate they never get decent
leadership afterwards I mean it's
extremely difficult to play the
intervention game Eisenhower of course
would be was much more reluctant to get
in but he always kept a NATO line firm
but he wasn't prepared to go into
Hungary and 56 he forced the Israelis
out of the Sinai principle in 1956 both
just before the election right taking
place um he basically did not get
involved big time in Lebanon I mean I
think he was pretty soon about it but on
the other hand he did understand that
one of the things you're trying to do is
to make sure that the Soviet threat
coming in Western Europe is going to be
met and all of a sudden you know Austria
gets divided in a sensible way you
managed to keep the German situation
relatively stable Japan becomes
relatively free Greece is no longer
threatened by the being and the thing he
actually did a lot of stuff that was
very good and of course this is a very
different world to where there were
essentially two superpowers as opposed
to a radically different idea
distribution of power and let's bring it
into the 2016 election and let's start
with foreign policy we have you know
three major candidates who are polling
levels say above 8%
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump and Gary
Johnson in terms of foreign policy do
you see any of them capable of
articulating a you know not necessarily
a foreign policy that you agree with but
a coherent strategy in the first place
and then do you agree with it or no well
let me start this with Donald come in
coherence is his middle name and he has
never thought hard about any problem in
the world except how it is he could
advance Donald Trump through means
private or public so I don't say you're
on the
Trump train it sounds like I mean but I
mean he just you know for example even
on domestic policies now in favor of
Faith Family leave um he's a pure
politician on this stuff and there's no
experience in international affairs and
what is so terribly deadly about him is
he also suffers from another obama
advice he doesn't know how to take
advice from anybody and he will not
bring around him any good people and no
good people will want to serve him so i
regard him as a disaster
hillary clinton I mean when she was
Secretary of State my friends at Hoover
who were the DX generals and so forth
thought that she was actually much more
competent than Obama in terms of the way
in which she was realistic and kind of
the assessment of these things but you
know after she goes out on the hustings
she now meets Bernie Sanders and she
starts making kind of public imperatives
and they do it's always dangerous look
maybe you don't want to go into Iraq
again but you don't want to say never
again because you don't know what's
gonna happen I asked with foreign policy
what were Hillary Clinton's big
successes know that generals but they're
like a but you know what they basically
didn't think that she had much power and
so their attitude was the way in which
it came back to me and this is all
fourth one thank you second here was
that in the deliberations they thought
she made more sense than the president
but he was such a strong-willed fellow
that he always did what exactly what he
wanted the Benghazi thing was the
classic evasion that you often see with
respect to people and you know Carol ko
is a distinguished anti-war guy when
he's a Dean at the air law school and
then writes these ridiculous memos to
the effect that we're shooting at them
and they're not shooting at us then it
turns out that we're not engaged in
military activities that would will
trigger some kind of requirements under
the declarations of wars acts and so
forth so I mean I think at this
particular point she is going to be
adrift my view about it is you know you
have to have a big stick but you can't
wield it in every particular case let me
and I think there's too much unilateral
surrender before the fight begins
talking more broadly you would mention
that Trump is incoherent he is walled
off for an expert advice other than that
which reflects what he already believes
Hillary Clinton you're worrying about
her and talk a little bit about the
Bernie Sanders effect on her not just in
terms of foreign policy but in general
policy and
are you worried I mean if you you
trash-talked Obama pretty well
do you have similar concerns about her
maybe not that she doesn't know a lot I
mean she's had a lot of experience in
office and you know and in and around
the White House but is she a she a bad
person to be President
well let me put it this way she
certainly is extremely thorough
extremely conscientious she briefs
pretty well and so forth um but the
difficulty is a does she have a core and
I think the answer to that question is
no I mean she's buffeted about and also
she isn't I mean in I mean she's not
like Sanders who's a true believer right
I mean the issue that you ask about her
is will she stay bought by anybody
because I mean she is in fact somebody
who kind of goes with the flow she was
the second most left senator when Obama
was the first most left senator in the
United States Senate this is back you
know before 2008 and I think she is
basically left her domestic policies on
things like labor are terrible and the
anti-discrimination was terrible and all
the rest of that stuff I think the
difference between her and Obama is that
she is temperamentally a little bit more
cautious afraid about her flanks being
attacked and so that was he's prepared
to go from here to there move very
rapidly she's gonna go more
incrementally with respect to what has
happened I also think that unlike other
people she does listen more to her
advisers I mean it is noted even around
this building the number of people who
are really rather able whom she's
recruited to work in her particular
campaign and they tend to be of this
sort of technocratic professorial types
and can we announce the news here you're
gonna be her Attorney General well
that's what that's the hope in their
plan yes yes actually I'm running for
all three guys right not gonna happen
but I mean she does have people who
actually Swan look even Obama had some
that was smart but it turns out nobody
matters but Valerie Jarrett and she's
just not up to that kind of good job
what about Gary Johnson he is doing
historically high for a Libertarian
Party candidate it's unlikely and you
know let's define unlikely as impossible
that he would win is he doing a good job
injecting libertarian discourse into
mainstream politics doesn't seem to be I
mean look I don't follow him
particularly closely and in fact I don't
think anybody follows him particularly
closely he is tended to get tied up in
things like the drug issues and so forth
which I think a tangential to the great
issues of America you know if he can't
pronounce the Leppa know where it is or
what's going on it's the kind of gaffe
that it's impossible to paper over no
matter how much you apologize
I thought his post Aleppo statement was
actually pretty good but in politics
that five-second gaffe gets 90% of the
attention and the two-minute thoughtful
apology gets in a 5% of 10% of the
attention well at that particular rate
you're going backwards he won't get into
the debates and we know why that
happened and that's not gonna give him a
chance to project himself he actually
has to share these side lights with Jill
Stein on the on the left-wing party so I
don't think that he's going to turn out
to be much of a force in this case I
think he will get votes but my guess is
that most of these votes of protest
votes I mean I understand perfectly well
people who say I cannot vote for a woman
who I think belongs in jail and I cannot
vote for a man whom I think is generally
emotionally and mentally unstable what
what did what has Hillary done that puts
her in jail well I mean oh if you
actually go through this stuff I mean
first of all the service situation the
creation and the use of a server whether
or not the leaks have taken place is in
fact pretty clearly a criminal offense
judge by a recklessness standard there's
probably a very strong set of
obstruction of justice charges that
could be made when you start wiping
these servers clean after you're on
notice of the fact that an investigation
it's going to take place in the second
Bush years there was an expansion of the
obstruction of justice statutes to cover
exactly cases like this and Qom we did
not even talk about them when he gave
his right watch saying I think she was
you know seriously negligent but not
culpably negligent which is double-talk
of the worst
well I'd also that if anybody else did
it he wants to reserve the right to my
madness and then of course I mean the
shenanigans that took place when they
dropped the whole investigation he
refuses to prosecute and lower it or
Lynch says I'm bound to accept his
advice she was just wrong the correct
thing to do is if she compromised
so is not the seed the authority to the
FBI who doesn't have it it's to find
somebody in her department who can
actually review these things I think
this whole case has gone forward without
anybody doing a serious memo on any
point of relevance with respect to the
mental states of the actus Reis the
particular conduct that goes plays there
is also I think the real question of
undue influence and cooperation with the
Clinton Foundation which was never stuck
to this and there is the very annoying
fact that the way in which this
investigation was conducted by the FBI
they did not follow standard procedures
they interviewed her at the end of the
process rather than at the beginning of
the process I don't know all the records
but that's part of the problem in this
particular case let me ask what the math
is completely off here you know one of
the things that I've heard you talk
about is you know what what happens when
every aspect of life becomes politicized
you know and obviously political
investigate or investigations of
political players are always politicized
but are we at a point where the United
States is essentially moving from a kind
of high trust society or a high trust
community where we kind of agree that
our leaders they're not perfect they're
not Saints but they're trying to do the
right thing and they pretty much follow
the laws that they write for the rest of
us - one in which you in which looks
more and more like southern Europe or
developing parts of the world where it's
like now you understand people go into
politics because they're bad people and
they act poorly rules get adjudicated
you know depending on who the subject is
so that if it's a wealthy connected
person they skate if it's somebody else
they get screwed do you feel like we're
going in that direction and then what
are some of the if so what are some of
the outcomes well the obvious situation
you just look at the difference in the
treatment to scooter libby who gets
charged after they set him up for
privilege things and hillary clinton who
manages to dodge this situation even
though i think the charges are really
very serious and they were delayed in
the enforcement and all the rest of it
that's at the top level but i do think
that's what's happened is two things
really matter
one is there's an increased polarization
inside this country the middle is
essentially hollowed out twenty years
ago bill clinton was at the center and
he was basically a right-wing demo
pretty pro-market respectful the bond
market more interventionist than you
would be but kind of committed to
keeping the welfare framework in place
now you look what's happened all of his
compromised positions are spurned
so the you know the Religious Freedom
Restoration Act the ACLU put it in place
very sensibly in 1993 they repudiated
today DOMA which is the stuff on
same-sex marriage is now
unconstitutional whereas it was at very
high consensus operation welfare reform
which seemed to work pretty well in the
1990s it's now basically regarded as a
terribly free trade free trade is gone
completely on the opposite direction and
so what about the Republicans or
conservatives who are constantly saying
now because Planned Parenthood gets some
money from the government not
specifically to do abortions like we
have to shut the government down well I
mean the polarization is imposed right I
think it's more on the Democratic side
than the Republican side but you're
right
and I mean the greatest mistake that
Newt Gingrich made was shutting down the
government when he had a disagreement
with Kennedy with the president in the
nineteen mid 1990s 1995 I guess at what
this is just absolutely sanity I don't
think this is true about Paul Ryan but
the best way to explain your position
which is quite credible is you get the
guys like Boehner and he resigns because
he can't deal with this Tea Party
opposition I mean they basically say we
are pure and ineffective that's we don't
get anything changed but we stand for
our principles he said we've got to make
compromises and he was done so I think
there's some of that on the Republican
side but I think in effect that the
biggest difference is the Republicans
who are being resistant to trying to
basically keep to the status quo while
the whole system is getting larger the
Democrats are moving very aggressively
to get things further to the left the
most conspicuous areas of this a banking
regulation and labor market regulation
and so forth I think it's really been
quite dramatic civil rights enforcement
has really been ratcheted up and I think
they're the ones who have tended to make
the main policy initiatives but look the
president in the modern economy being a
single office with a single man is more
powerful than a divided and confused
Congress and what we're seeing I think
it's fair to say
unfortunately is this playing forward
with a guy who is in my judgment a very
weak president because he doesn't know
the limits sensible limits that
shouldn't be imposed upon himself but if
you look at our Constitution I'll just
end on this note there are lots of gaps
in what it does and what you need to do
is to have comedy a sense of
self-restraint so that people continue
to operate in what you say is this
high-cost environment but now the
tendency is everybody pushes their legal
rights to the limit these soft buffers
tend to be understated and you're gonna
get much more ugly confrontations then
that effect is going to be a slow
decline in American growth happiness
prosperity and wisdom and so you know
the trajectory is down the first order
of business is to reduce the rate of
decline the second order of the business
is to try to get it into reverse I'm a
little skeptical i yeah I'd say a little
the lights are going out all over
America very quick less what is a worse
scenario a Hillary presidency or a trump
presidency well it's high variability on
both sides I think and it depends on
which Trump shows up Hillary I think you
know what she's gonna do she's gonna
push hard to the left with in
conventional reasons and not do anything
crazy
with Trump if he kind of as it were
keeps to the script he could possibly be
better on the high side on deregulation
and domestic issues and maybe a better
farm negotiator in part because he's a
little bit crazy but if he goes insane
then in effect god knows what's going to
happen and so the argument in favor of
Hillary's it's a low median and a low
variance and the argument in favor of
Trump is it's a low meeting and a high
variance if you think he's gonna be high
you do one thing low another thing how
are you gonna vote for
I'm gonna sit out this I mean I can't
bring myself to vote for either of these
particular candidates and to me I'll
just end on this no I am an academic I
know it sounds odd buying a candidates
like buying a market basket of goods
half of what you want to throw out I
think it's not a basket of deplorable
yes yes so whatever and so by not voting
for either of them are free to criticize
each of them with the praise them as it
may be on an issue-by-issue basis I'm an
issue guy I'm not a candidate guy in
this world nobody's going to ever
me for public office I hope I have some
influence on the opinion I hope that
even our sparring on this issue is of
interest to the audience that invited
that we're hoping to attract so thank
you well thank you very much we will
leave it there we have been talking with
Richard Epstein he is an NYU professor
of law he's also at University of
Chicago law and the Hoover Institution
Richard thanks so much for your time
oh is great for Reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie